let's take a quick look at how to use
the Google cloud sequel proxy go to
cloud google.com and open up your cloud
console go to the sequel section here
you can see your cloud sequel instances
if you don't have a cloud sequel
instance you can create one click your
instance to be taken to the instance
overview page now go to the access
control tab and then go to the users tab
specify a new root password go to the
following page to follow along with the
rest of the tutorial scroll down and
click enable the API choose your project
and click continue the API should now be
enabled follow the installation
instructions for your operating system
now run g-cloud auth application default
loggin go back to the sequel overview
page and copy the instant connection
name run the cloud sequel proxy and pass
in your instance connection name at the
end of the string you also want type in
equal to TCP : 3 3 0 6 you now have a
direct connection to cloud sequel
through the local proxy